[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonne année bonne et heureuse année à
tous les petits enfants alors par roanne
nicolas à pimprenelle et à tes petits
neveux
mon cher nounours qu'il grandisse en
beauté et en sagesse et bien je descends
voir si cette nouvelle à nu les a rendus
sage patron et hop on le chauffe eau
propre aux propos auront des impacts
message
voilà votre tante ont dû maison
renchérit bébés devenus non ils sont
prêts à partir des neveux ils ont envie
de retrouver leurs moments emilia qu'ils
ont même préparé tu es beau cadeau pour
elle je vois on l'appelle trompette auto
c'est pour maman puis rémy ou c'est un
bijou tout doré mais c'est la tour eiffe
à une annonce quand je suis père se voit
des enfants aux le bol flosse ce qu'il
était dans l va être contente
emilia l esstic auquel dinan ce qu'est
ce que c'est que tout ça les cadeaux que
je vous ai apporté se met à faire du
bruit chaque nuit nounours ouais et tu
mettais pas de celle qui tue et aigle au
bout avec ma soeur mais c'est pas
contenir des moissons bon j'étais avec
mon avis ça va ça elle vous en avez fait
du bruit on a dansé chanté un tout petit
peu c'était le réveillon est pareil que
tu as très bien et que tu chantes de
drôle de chanson pourrait punir
tu vas nous l'a chanté et la dass et
pour tout et tout de suite avant de
repartir en voyage
d'accord mais en feront
[Musique]
produits les grands le prime
oui où les bulls
oui oui je vous le dis
oui bon rouler cool
ce soir j j faites du bruit c'est le
bowling ou lit
on lit tous les avis oui oui holy naître
ou bien seuls
9 ou 10 ou lé nounours le dis on obéit
on va au lit au lit
[Musique]
rami au nord cela ou l'hydraulique houle
au libouli hollywood vous
non je vous dis on lit au lit au lit est
bonne mais oui bonne nuit au lit bonne
nuit les grands les petits bonne nuit
le grand le petit
[Musique]
audi dans ce que des douanes ouf je le
suis les enfants merci ballon il faut
que nous partions route mais ne veut
dinos vous reviendrez bientôt tu
ramèneras rémi toto et fanfan le produit
les enfants annonce quelques provisions
pour la route
merci péché leurs petits à bientôt à
l'eau en avant mes neveux là au revoir
mes petits enfants
tout le monde est là oui pas trop alors
en route
karim il ya nous attend avec impatience
et si vous êtes bien sage des enfants
nous reviendrons très bientôt vous voir
se jurer sur la tête de mason au revoir
tous nos amis
à bientôt à john tonneaux a mis au menu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]